bonsoir fola merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france donc les
adversaires de benyamin nétanyahou ans
jusqu'à minuit pour parvenir à un accord
leur est donc en l'imaginent aux
dernières tractations
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur ces négociations le chef de
l'opposition et la trace jusqu'à les
ennemis d'israël tant deux heures afin
de dire au président israélien ci est en
position ou pas de former un
gouvernement de majorité pour le moment
cela n'est toujours pas clair elle joue
un logo nous avons récemment reçu des
rapports disant qu'un tel politicien de
7 et de commissions de majorité s'est
retiré la coalition recouvre 61 sur 120
sièges parlementaires
une seule défection signifierait la
perte de la majorité et l'impossibilité
de former un gouvernement de majorité
il est très difficile de se prononcer
pour le moment mais depuis plusieurs
heures et il ya des rencontres
on passa entre des politiciens qui avec
une cohorte des accords secrets de plus
aujourd'hui on a également beaucoup
parlé de la posture de ilike est le
numéro deux du parti yamina yamila
signifie en droit de ces le parti de la
droite il faut les chéquiers politique
israélien dirigé par nathalie bennatan
elle souhaite être chargé de la
sélection des juges de la cour suprême
un autre politicien s'y opposent du
parti travailliste
donc il y a beaucoup de tractations et
on ne sait encore pas vraiment ce qu'il
va arriver à cette heure paula sans
faire dans la voyance avant la boule de
cristal qu'elle pourrait être l'issue la
plus probable est rien chaque heure
charge
c'est un petit peu sage bon je vous
aurais dit qu'il est je vous dirai pour
le moment qu'à 70% il n'y aura pas de
gouvernement de coalition
il y a deux heures je vous aurais dit
exactement le contraire que à 70%
j'étais certain qu'il y aurait un
gouvernement de coalition
donc c'est très difficile de se
prononcer le grand problème c'est que
nous ne savons pas quels sont les
accords les promesses complet par
exemple cats ont promis aux affaires du
parti arabe dame ses soutiens faisait
partie de la coalition et maintenant
nous expliquer que des politiques de la
droite pouvait se retirer de la
coalition ce qui signifierait que trop
de faveur ont été octroyés aux partis
arabes ce n'est qu'un exemple des
nombreuses transactions en cours et la
déclaration doit se faire en moins de
deux heures avant l'échéance de minuit
si le chef de l'opposition hier la pid
il ne peut pas dire au président et sera
lien qui elle a réussi à former un
gouvernement de coalition majoritaire
alors le problème va se retrouver devant
le parlement israélien et les
parlementaires dont le premier ministre
actuel benyamin nétanyahou auront
plusieurs semaines afin d'essayer de
former
une coalition majoritaire mais cela
semble peu probable et il y aura
peut-être plus tôt sans doute de
nouvelles sélections la quatrième
élection espace de deux ans justement en
vue de l'extérieur paula on a le
sentiment que ce scénario se filmer
rejouer très régulièrement en ifren et
que finalement à chaque fois il vient
cbnm de benyamin nétanyahou qui gagne
c'est tout à fait vrai c'est la même
perception ils sont les israéliens au
sein du fil ça soutient l'appel le
magicien car il semble toujours réussir
à revenir à tu pouvoir
donc il faudrait faire attention avant
d'exclure cette possibilité il est
impossible de tierra à ce stade si
l'opposition pourra annoncer une
majorité avant minuit et même si
l'opposition y réussit alors cela ne
suffit pas que banny montagne où va se
retirer
c'est le premier ministre de l'histoire
d'israël qui a gouverné le plus
longtemps et même s'il ne gagne pas il
pourrait passer à l'opposition et
devenir chef de l'opposition et même
dans cette position s'il y avait un
nouveau gouvernement et alors ce
gouvernement serait composé de sept
partis politiques très différents des
partis de droite des partis de gauche
qui ont très peu de choses en commun
leur seul point commun c'est qu'ils
souhaitent le départ de taye netanyahu
et même dans un scénario idéal ce
gouvernement si il réussit à être formé
pourrait ne durer que quelques mois
il y aurait donc de nouvelles élections
et s'il ya de nouvelles élections en
israël pagnol in time en aura de nouveau
une chance de retrouver son poste le
premier ministre
donc le magicien déploie ses sortilèges
les il est inquiet et lui aussi organise
beaucoup de rencontres fait beaucoup de
promesses à des politiciens afin de les
encourager à rejoindre son camp et non
pas celui de l'opposition
merci beaucoup paula flyers journées
sportives internationales en direct de
tel aviv où évidemment au courant de la
suite des événements merci à vous